Among those who use recreational drugs, Bill
Murray is something of an icon, having played
several pot-smoking characters over the years,
including the cannabis-loving sea captain
Steve Zissou from The Life Aquatic with Steve
Zissou, and noted drug user Hunter S. Thompson
in Where the Buffalo Roam.
So, was Bill Murray actually arrested for
transporting Mary Jane, or was this story
just an urban legend concocted by Murray’s
pot-smoking fanbase?
Believe it or not, this story is actually
true.
Murray was arrested for this on his 20th birthday…not
exactly the best way to celebrate such a happy
occasion.
Here’s how it went down: on September 21st,
1970, Murray was trying to catch a flight
to Denver.
At the time, Murray was a pre-med student
(yes, you read that right) at Regis University
in Colorado.
But Murray never made his flight back to school…partially
because of a stupid joke.
While Murray is considered a gifted comedian
today, at age 20, he still needed to hone
his craft.
Perhaps he had been smoking a bit before arriving
at Chicago’s O’Hare International Airport,
because while waiting to board the plane,
he joked to a fellow passenger that his suitcase
contained two bombs…
Unfortunately for Murray, a ticket agent overheard
his comment and alerted the authorities.
Of course, Murray didn’t have “two bombs”,
but his luggage did contain a staggering amount
of grass.
To be precise, Murray had five “bricks”
of marijuana in his possession, which weighed
a total of about 10 pounds.
That much weed was worth $20,000 at the time,
or about $117,000 today.
That said, even if Murray hadn’t been running
his mouth, he would have been caught red-handed.
Chicago’s finest vice detectives were already
on the scene waiting for Murray, having gotten
a tip about his suitcase full of drugs.
Suffice it to say, Murray was arrested and
put on probation for five years.
During that time, his doctoral aspirations
were put on hold.
However, Regis did award him an honorary doctorate
in 2007.
(Student loans not necessary!)
Incidentally, when he accepted the doctorate,
he did so wearing pajama shorts and top, with
a suit jacket over them.
Five years after his arrest, Murray was vaulted
into the limelight when he was cast on Saturday
Night Live, but it wasn’t the Saturday Night
Live most know today.
Rather, he was cast on ABC’s Saturday Night
Live with Howard Cosell.
The show was canceled after the first season,
but Murray quickly found work as a replacement
to Chevy Chase in NBC’s Saturday Night Live,
which was just into its second season.
And the rest is comedy history.
The Illinois State Police report on Murray’s
O’Hare arrest recorded Murray’s weight
as 170 pounds in 1970.
His skin was described as “ruddy”.